[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport l'émission ne surtout pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local comme vous le voyez ici on
est obligé de porter le masque vu les
conditions sanitaires du moment mais ça
ne va pas nous empêcher de décrypter
l'actualité sportive du département
pendant une heure pour m'accompagner nos
chroniqueurs et chroniqueuse sont avec
nous sur ce plateau il via écran
interposé suit également en contexte
sanitaire présentation en musique on
commence à ma droite il est de retour
sur ce un plateau c'est une grande
gueule il n'a pas peur de dire ce qu'il
pense et la star de cette émission
l'incroyable le magnifique coach jean
miss est avec une pendant une heure mais
bon soir mickaël vous aura tous comment
allez-vous coach toujours grande de
forme m'avait le match qu'un parce que
ça c'est pas pratique main c'est un peu
spécial 1 pour vous l'autre dumas ce que
la fédération française de rugby voilà
oui si vous placez côte marqué ce jour
n'ont remarqué ces valeurs simplement
j'espère que ces malheurs le message est
passé on continue notre tour de table à
gauche musique c'est également la
superstar de ce taux qu'il est aussi
technique qu'andrea pirlo aussi bon à la
finition que pippo inzaghi aussi
infidèle que francesco totti c'est
l'italienne lover grégory cas là les
journalistes chez tv 78 qui nous fait
l'honneur de venir sur cette émission
nouvelle fois comparé à tous ces
légendes du foot bonjour michael bond
longeant c'est un plaisir de retrouver
jean en plateau et bonjour à tous et
vous êtes un petit mélange des trois non
je n'aurais pas la prétention de me
comparer à ces légendes mais en tout cas
ça me fait plaisir merci pour ce message
on continue en visio musique il s'est
remis au sport depuis début janvier on
suit avec attention ses progrès à chaque
émission son objectif faire l'émission
torse nu cet été le capitaine yann
dujarrier du club de vélizy 78 est avec
nous pendant une heure quand allez-vous
yann
pas super bien là ya un souci est que ma
musique je suis si excité
à oui effectivement j'ai pas j'ai pas
fait attention est ce qu'on peut lui
mettre un tout petit peu de sable et sa
musique ou pas si c'est possible orgie
sinon je vais me fâcher
voilà la musique de yens déjà riez alors
les yvelinois veulent savoir il ya du
jarrier comment se déroule votre
entraînement depuis début janvier
joe des mails lors des tonnes de mails
ici ils figurez vous qu aujourd'hui j'ai
mis une de bronze sur même parcours
qu'il ya quinze jours donc plutôt
content sur une demi-heure d'avoir gagné
une minute sur sur un circuit de 5 km
donc ça me va bien en progression à
progresser voilà les héninois sont
contents de le savoir on continue en
visio à musique lui aussi très sportif
il adore sortir les biceps quand il le
faut dans une bd ou dans un débat
télévisé nous vient tout droit de
versailles on le surnomme le gladiateur
pire chevaliers du rugby-club de
versailles est avec nous
formé bonheur à tous les cantons grands
chefs et des effets spéciaux parce que
c'est pas parce qu'on est en visio qu'on
n'a pas de la technique on n'a pas du
coach et j'ai ouïe ouïe digne des plus
grandes émissions de télévision bravo
pierre chevalier
enfin notre dernière chroniqueuse
musique c'est sa première émission de
télévision satellite noise est très
sportive elle a commencé très tôt le
sport en faisant notamment du judo et du
saut en hauteur à la joue au tennis au
basket aujourd'hui elle fait de la
course à pied elle a notamment fait des
semi-marathons également la cavalcade de
poissy elvis d'étrelles de l'extrême un
marathon dans les prochaines années
mesdames et messieurs audrey le père est
avec nous pendant une heure mais merci
sion et bonjour la team du plateau est
une vision merci michael pour
l'habitation et
voilà on va voir qui va être le plus
efficace entre l'atim vision et la team
plateau en tout cas jean alfred en forme
alors attention
prête pour cette grande première du coup
je changerais très bien on comprend
combien
à deux comme en foot on va voir ça alors
avant de passer au programme de
l'émission commence tout de suite par du
un football ou plutôt une page people
c'est comme vous préférez le rappeur
américain kanye west ça vous parle kanye
west gens oui oui bien sûr j'ai tous ses
disques
alors il était de passage à paris pour
la fashion week il en a profité pour
faire un tour dans les yvelines il est
venu rencontrer le brésilien neymar au
camp des loges le centre d'entraînement
du psg à saint germain en laye la star
internationale a salué les joueurs il a
reçu un maillot du club de la part du
coût du brésilien neymar un maillot
floqué du numéro 10 et de son nouveau
nom y briller on commet dit à gregory j
ai oui parce que kanye west maintenant
il veut qu'on l'appelle lié sait c'est
l'un de ses petits caprices ans les
stars on sait qu'elles ont souvent des
gros caprice alors votre avis du coup
sûr cette visite on va faire un petit
tour de table si je peux dire grégory
non mais c'est toujours sympa de voir
des stars de sports différents se
rencontrent et on avait vu un kobe
bryant qui était venu bien sûr avant sa
disparition il était venu au camp des
loges également rencontré les joueurs du
psg se anecdotique mais c'est aussi dans
peut-être aussi un une vision
stratégique du psg on sait qu'il ya un
contrat avec jordan que kanye west est
aussi ambassadeur de cette marque qui a
un contrat qui a été a été menée ceci
dans la vision du psg je pense d'abord
une vision toujours plus internationale
ils vont ouvrir une boutique au premier
semestre à new york donc c'est purement
dans cette stratégie d'exister un peu
plus mondialement il ya des boutiques un
peu court un peu partout dans le monde
et peut-être pour des rares c'est
l'occasion de commencer sa reconversion
lui qui dit qu'il arrêtera peut-être le
foot après le mondial 2022 on sait qu'il
aime la musique on le voit souvent dans
des clubs dans des clips de funk
brésilienne donc pourquoi pas aussi une
reconversion dans la musique je ne sais
pas donc ça c'est la petite bugs mais je
pense que c'est avant tout peut-être
pour le paris saint-germain
de développer cette marque à
l'international et on sait que kanye
west et une renommée internationale
audrey qu'est ce que vous en pensez
maccioni ex-amant doué pour faire le
buzz pour faire parler de lui et il ya
eu franchement il a choisi le milliard
jouable nemak effectivement se fait bien
connaître le terrain des réseaux sociaux
est aussi sombre et liszt donc mais
enfin mais marque effectivement une star
qui colle on connaît la fois sur les
liaisons et qui est très proche des fans
et puis bah kanye west je pense qu'il a
envie de se faire reconnaître et encore
plus aujourd'hui
avec son divorce avec kim kardashian
donc il va la fois où trouver un peu ses
doigts le web des réseaux sociaux je
suis bien à lyon le petit courgain
goerig mais un trait partenariat bleus
de stratégie c'est une première ça non
buzz jackson et
pour mon époux à être une image on voit
que le mariage peut peut fonctionner
entre les deux entités pierre chevalier
moi j'ai ça veut dire deux choses sur
cette émission qui cette élection par
les sports on parle de sport la première
c'est que on est on est vraiment dans
l'accélération depuis qu'est depuis de
nombreuses années de la peopolisation
des joueurs de foot ça c'est la première
chose et la deuxième c'est pas très
rassurant après les après les tours de
coupe de france et a besoin la ligue des
champions de voir même un plus dans les
médias et sur les réseaux sociaux
question de fair un bon après c'est vrai
que tu as fait des coups de com et ça ça
promeut la marque lamarthe sg mais je ne
peux pas m'empêcher de décorréler par
rapport à la
hausse enjeux sportifs sur claude
échéances qui attendent le psg en disant
que détour d'un petit peu la tension
mais ne perdons pas de prise de vue les
objectifs il ya du jarrier qu'est ce que
vous en pensez neymar magnifique
ambassadeur pour le psg ou kanye west un
magnifique ambassadeur pour le psg j'en
ai rien à
vous avez commencé par un carton journal
as
c'est obligé
j'assume le carton n'y a pas de problème
ouais c'est alors moi je suis pas du
tout people je viens d'apprendre que
kanye west était séparé avec kim
kardashian voyez donc
voilà notre niveau de bon niveau de
culture culture people
peut-être
c'est quand même bien pour la marque psg
peut-être gagneriez oui alors vous savez
mon amour pour la marque psg un mois la
mienne elle est plutôt dans le sud de la
france donc c'est pareil
c'est pas j'aime bien parler du psg
quand il quand il brille sur les
terrains j'aime bien qu'intéressé le jeu
vu les prestations dernière sur sur les
termes je pense qu il va falloir un
petit peu se reconcentrer parce qu'il ya
des échéances qui arrivent très
prochainement et il lit on en connaît
qui vont pas leur faire de cadeau donc
ce serait dommage encore une fois de
passer un tour
et grégory dit que vous allez droit au
but 1-1 il ya déjà rien
du genre qu'est ce que vous en pensez
kanye west alors vous êtes un grand fan
on l'a compris il arrive et va quelques
quelques minutes de nos studios qu'est
ce que ça vous fait mais j'espère qu'il
me veut pas pro de lui avoir piqué
kardashian
sinon
sinon je me poserai la question quand
même est ce que dément pas jouer au
football avant d'honorer la dette qui
commettent ces missiles actuellement
quand est-ce qu'ils commencent à jouer
perso
et oui l'autre non mais quand même oui
c'est bien vous l'avez tout a été dit
ici tout a été dit c'est bien conversion
va mais quand même je pense pas qu'il ya
4-5 kc-45 en haute guinée maria je crois
pas qu'on a recruté avec le psg a
recruté ce jour-là de ce niveau là avec
cette classe sur le papier qu'il avait
pour en faire une star avec le l'image
du psg jeu parce qu'il attendait plus de
lui des performances de tes règles et
non pas des performances sur le
publicité il ya une phrase importante
qui peut être montre aussi que y aura
jamais peut-être deux matches entre
neymar lpg il a dit je ne me sentirai
jamais ici c'est ce qu'il dit dans le
documentaire qui est sorti justement sur
netflix donc je voulais juste ajouter
une chose je vais vous dire une phrase
je parle à dieu tous les jours c'est mon
meilleur ami il joue au foot dans mon
jardin je crois que je vois mais si bas
ça c'est une phrase d'un titre de kanye
west qui s'appelle off the grid et ça
peu simple sas a pu surprendre qu'il n'y
ait pas eu de rencontre justement entre
kanye west et messi au moment du passage
au camp des loges il a rencontré plus
tôt neymar mais apparemment il est fan
de messi a en tout cas de neymar mais
peut-être plus de temps que messier
gator aussi je pense a pour autres pour
dire ce que j'avais et le le le le vfm
uba gc mais sa femme est si ce n'est pas
alors nous allons maintenant passer au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler de tennis arthur enoch
nash a déclaré forfait pour le deuxième
tour de l'open d'australie coup de
projecteur également sur tony yoka le
sportif évinoise sera privé d'une
demi-finale ipf des poids lourds mais
avant de parler de ces thèmes on va
continuer à parler football et de la
coupe de france
[Musique]
alors une fois n'est pas coutume on va
tout de suite commencer par l'envolée de
grégory le moment fort le nirvana de
cette émission alors de quoi allez vous
nous parlez à grégory si vous avez un
petit zay sur le sujet de cette envolée
mais avant de vous en dire plus je vous
propose de regarder cet extrait
j'ai envie de voir cette saison mickaël
un petit poucet yvelinois arrivé loin
dans cette coupe de france est une
compétition où les rêves sont permis on
a vu par exemple l'équipe de quevilly ou
encore calais en 2000 qui était arrivé à
les amateurs au stade de france en
finale de cette coupe de france est en
ces temps difficiles on a besoin d'une
belle histoire au club yvelinois des
emmène de nous la raconter c'était le
sujet de ma première envolée lorsque
j'ai eu le plaisir de rejoindre cette
très belle équipe du sop voit ses
pouvoirs un petit poucet yvelinois
performer dans la coupe de france j'ai
été entendu une saison plus tard mais
tout de même la coupe de france c'est
tard que jamais mieux vaut tard que
jamais a comme on dit la coupe de france
1 sanction c'est celle de tous les
possibles une épopée de belle histoire
qui s'écrit chaque année et pour cette
105e édition deux clubs amateurs l'ont
écrit cette histoire c'est bergerac et
bien sûr versailles qui elle nous la
raconte il manquait encore un export
quand il faut le dire aux hommes de
youssef chibi dans la compétition
toulouse le solide leader de ligue 2 se
dressait face à eux pour les huitièmes
de finale la rencontre aurait dû se
jouer à versailles mais a été à déplacer
dans la ville rose faute de stade mont
boron homologué cela n'augurait rien de
bon pour nos yvelinois j'avais peur que
tout se termine ici et fort heureusement
une fois de plus les pronostics étaient
erronées ils ont fait des victoires 1 à
0 de versailles avec un but de djoko
dans le dernier quart d'heure quelle
performance versailles c'est royal c'est
même le titre qui a été choisi par
l'équipe dans sa une alternative au
lendemain de cette performance car le
club a largement mérité sa victoire deux
divisions d'écart séparait les deux
équipes et ça ne s'est pas vu sur le
terrain avec un versailles souvent
dominateur et des joueurs qui ont
réalisé une prestation majuscule il n'y
a qu'à voir le but est cette
construction de l'action pour voir que
le potentiel de ce petit il ya des tout
le potentiel pour devenir un grand du
football un grand peut-être on l'espère
un jour du football français alors j'en
suis convaincu nous sommes qu'au début
de cette belle histoire racontée par les
versaillais les ambitions sont grandes
pour l'avenir les espoirs sont également
permis pour intégrer le dernier carré de
cette coupe de france est au travers de
son parcours versailles fait briller les
yvelines braye et brille elle même plus
encore non aversa il n'y a pas que le
château il ya aussi des clubs sportifs
qui ont des projets et travaille on
pense forcément football je faire un
petit clin d'oeil à pierre aussi avec le
cumul le rugby-club de versailles
également n'oublions pas que la cité
royale aussi accueillera les jeux
olympiques ce sera un site olympique en
2024 alors les coéquipiers de berck avec
le capitaine ont déjà marqué l'histoire
du club mais ne nous arrêtons pas là des
pages encore plus sublime peuvent être
écrites deux matches désormais c'est par
les versaillais du stade de france et de
cette finale de la coupe de france
encore un dernier effort il ne faut rien
lâcher quoi qu'il arrive à un
pensionnaire de nationale 2 sera en demi
finales puisque nos yvelines ont hérité
de bergerac pour les quarts de finale
c'est beau pour le sport amateur qui a
en plus souffert de la pandémie on en a
largement parlé ici sur ce plateau mais
nous sommes avant tout aux yvelinois
donc on va être chauvin et défenseurs de
ce sport yvelinois aller les yvelines et
bien sûr aller versailles quelle belle
envolée grégory je vais peut-être vous
faire réagir pierre il vous a interpellé
rigoriste
sur le sur le côté archives archives de
cette édition est un pronostic à ce
qu'on sait on sait à quel point nous
sommes nous sommes très pertinent dans
nos bottes dans nos pronostics et
notamment grégory quand l'italie le jus
ou pas oui
je suis je suis ravi de voir que grec
s'est trompé
j'espère et dire une défaite de
versailles contre bergerac au prochain
tour ça on n'en parlera plus tard notre
île très très belles envolées parce que
ça résume ça résume en quelques en
quelques lignes quelques envolées la
joie qui hélas non depuis depuis
dimanche et avec cette magnifique
victoire est ce match ce match qui fait
référence parce que comme comme
d'agorila rappelé jusqu'à maintenant
c'était un tour c'était au tour de coupe
de france qui était à la portée à la
porte de versailles avec des équipes qui
étaient pas forcément très très bien
classés parmi les gros ou de ligue 2
voire des nationales et là c'était un
vrai gros test à toulouse en plus on n'a
pas pu profiter du tirage au sort et
recevoir averses
déménagé à toulouse ce sont hostiles ils
ont gagné et de belle manière et c'est
tina confirmation de toutes les
promesses
je rappelle qu'on ne peut pas jouer à
versailles parce qu'on ne peut pas voir
de lumière depuis la chambre du roi
soleil
de sources lumineuses pour être précis
source lumineuse avec avec l'élimination
des habitants à versailles ils peuvent
allumer leur lumière le soir audrey
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous de cette victoire de cette
qualification de versailles à gens me
disaient tu peux dire c'est vrai qui est
pas grand monde qui leur côté mais je
suis aussi contente de voir lors qu ils
ont beaucoup le fait que se sont pas
laissé impressionner par les grands
groupes tels que quelques toulouse je
pense qu'aussi c'est bon club qui monte
qui monte ça ça montre à quel point il
ya un esprit d équipe et aussi une
technicité et aussi ce côté
effectivement vient de gagner donc
encore plus de motivation et de
dynamisme donc c'est vrai que c'est une
blague propre deledeuil le sou et je me
permets de lâcher une petite foule de
doucier dry comme tout le monde le sait
à versailles il y aurait versailles
contre poissy et le match sera à poissy
au stade léo lagrange il faudra laisser
gagner 1 pour pas qu'ils soient trop
fatigué pour la coupe de france un point
s'il
ya déjà dit qu'est ce que vous en pensez
de cette envolée
ok on est tous très très content et un
après par contre vous aviez pour le
stick et une victoire de versailles
alors ça je suis j'aurais aimé que vous
allier retrouver les images de 15 jours
quand moi alors mon côté très chauvin
m'empêche de pouvoir dire que qui vont
perdre même si ils sont pas favoris d'un
d'un match je ne peux pas voir un
sportif français perdent contre un
étranger c'est pas possible il n'allait
pas dans ma conception de du chauvinisme
voilà je sais c'est un peu trop forte
pour moi donc oui j'avais dit versailles
vainqueur et alors je ne fais plus le
score mais je sais que j'étais le seul à
l'avoir à l'avoir à l'avoir dit c'est
c'est comme ça quand le coeur parle il
regagne un point donc donc non voilà on
est très content c'est que ça fait quand
même quelques années qu'on suit les
clubs de des yvelines sur les coupes de
france et est souvent ça s'arrête ça
s'arrête de bonheur donc là on est
content on est des gens on est en
février et on a toujours un club dans la
tue et c'est ce que l'on souhaitait
depuis depuis très très longtemps
maintenant il va falloir que ce ne soit
pas qu'un coup d'essai que l'année
prochaine déjà et on me dira fasse
encore une belle continue d'une belle
suite et puis maintenant on va profiter
du match contre bergerac et on va
essayer d'en prochain ils vont essayer
d'en profiter pour aller pour aller
gratter une place en demi finale et là
ce serait ce serait quand même à une
très belle finalité parce que c'est
qu'ils ont ils ont toujours voulu
rencontrer un très gros donc une ligue 1
et pour l'instant ce n'a pas été le cas
donc en demi finale
normalement il y aura plus le choix
genre qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous
de cette qualification
c'est ce que grégory a dit tout à
l'heure c'est la magie de la coupe de
phrases c'est simple réglable voilà ces
clubs qui se sont pas les grands les
grands de ceux du don qui gagne tout le
temps et voilà deux divisions en dessous
et à plus à l'extérieur à toulouse 1
leader de ligue 2 c'est une si tu ne
s'élance de très très belles
performances et l'a ensuite bon prono
bergerac je pense que je pense qu'il
rêvait autour d'autres choses mais ils
ont certainement vu voulu prendre une
grosse tête d'affiché clubs de ligue 1
pour pour pour vivre encore plus et
vivre encore plus lors leur leur belle
épopée mais ça veut dire a plus qu ils
prennent un club du même niveau mais qui
eux je crois qu'ils ont sorti un ou deux
clubs de l'oeil aux sorties mais s'ils
ont sorti saint-etienne est aussi le
traité qui évolue en national dont
qu'ils ont sorti déjà ils ont fait trois
exploits déjà dans cette coupe de france
où ils ont pris 0 buts encaissés et zéro
but en sept matches et voilà malgré la
performance et est arrivé en quart de
finale je pense que le tirage n'est pas
n'est pas super favorable pour les deux
raisons que j'ai évoquées bon à regarder
justement la réaction des joueurs après
le tirage de cette coupe de france
c'était du coup ce lundi 31 janvier
c'était sur france télévisions et
regardez les joueurs se sont réunis et
ils ont réagi suite à ce tirage contre
bergerac
[Applaudissements]
le moule
bon vous l'avez vu ce n'était pas le bon
extrême est en tout cas des images de
joie c'est ça fait toujours plaisir à
voir on va écouter tout de suite
l'interview des joueurs de versailles au
delà de jouer bergerac on est surtout
triste de devoir souvent pour notre
public ça reste un match de coupe quand
même mais c'est surtout une place qui
jouant pour la demi finale et on va te
donner de façon on se dit que tout est
possible pour aller en demi finale du
coup on va faire un petit vote est ce
que c'est un bon ou un mauvais tirage
vous votez oui ou non
vous êtes partagés
non pour vous pierre non pour vous
grégory vous êtes partagés pousse alors
pour vous c'est oui à audrey du coup
alors alors on y croit d'accord alors on
fait un petit duel entre eux alors
qu'ils y étaient contre déjà pierre
pierre et audrey aller audrey du coup
pourquoi pourquoi vous êtes vous pensez
que c'est un bon tirage mais il faut
faire confiance à un petit peu de temps
en temps c'est à dire que oui on s'est
rachetés fait je pense été fait de
manière stratégique et aussi en allemand
et vous bien réfléchi qu'elle explique
saunier où je fais confiance pierre moi
je pense que c'est pas un c'est pas un
critère de de
confiance en leurs rangs de l'équipe ils
ont montré eux et c'est versailles peu
qu'ils étaient là et qui pouvait passer
qui pouvait passer n'importe quel petit
ou gros il ya notamment le notamment
toulouse en ligue 2 je trouve que c'est
à ce niveau des coupes de france en
quart de finale déjà ils ont atteint un
objectif historique c'est à dire de m de
battre justement ce niveau de haut
niveau de qualification en allant au
caire maintenant ça reste ça reste
ouvert et je trouve que c'est pas un
mauvais tirage parce que à ce stade pour
évoquer la magie de gens que je rappeler
la magie de la coupe de france il ya un
moment ou un autre de toute façon s'il
faut y aller au bout il faut il faut se
goinfrer un gros et c'était le tour idée
l'un aux quarts de finale puisque
l'historique était était déjà battu pour
recevoir on pourra les aléas
imaginez s'ils s'étaient qualifiés et
j'ai un psg versailles au parc des
princes ou alors à l'om ou alors à
nantes mais je trouve que là ils ont
plus de difficultés à affronter une
équipe de leur niveau de nationale 2 où
puiser leur ressemblent beaucoup parce
qu'elle est leader ainsi de son groupe
de l'autre groupe de nationale 2 et je
pense qu'ils vont avoir une pression
supplémentaire
qu'il n'aurait pas eu si la dé
rencontrer en quarts de finale en ligue
2 ou en ligue 1 parce que justement
c'est des niveaux équivalents cd saison
qui sont équivalentes avec des matches
gagnés et s'il allait affronter un gros
il y aurait eu zéro pression puisqu'on
ne les aurais pas attendu toute la
contrée bergerac on se dit que c'est
possible on vise la demi-finale lé match
va être vraiment vraiment accroché c'est
en ce sens que je dit c'est pas
forcément un bon tirage yanji ariège qui
vous a convaincu est ce que c'est un bon
ou un mauvais tirage
je reste je reste partagée on saura si
c'est un bon tirage après la après fin
du match tout simplement ce mission
gagne on saura si c'était un bon tirage
bon tirage
en tout cas le match a déjà commencé un
sur les réseaux sociaux à grégory ya une
petite embrouille un ces centres oui
mickaël michel responsable communication
du club et le président de bergerac
ouais c'est plus de la tête de la
taquinerie parce que on ne sait toujours
pas à l'heure où on enregistre cette
émission l'information doit être révélé
il faut le dire dans l'après-midi à peu
tomber au moment d'enregistrement de
l'émission ou est-ce que se disputera le
match on sait que c'est bergerac qui
reçoit à versailles mais à bergerac il
ya le même souci à versailles le style
le stade n'est pas homologué donc on ne
peut pas recevoir à bergerac donc
parlement trois solutions qui s'offrent
pour pour cette rencontre le jouet le
stade à périgueux ça a été le cas pour
les huitièmes de finale et la victoire
de bergerac face à saint-etienne un
stade qui est à 50 km donc de bergerac
6000 places pour ce stade francis
rongiéras ce mais là encore il n'ya pas
d'homologation officielle pour ce stade
là
le dernier match ils ont pu le jouer
parce qu'ils ont une dérogation de la
part de la fédération française de
football et donc ça c'est le stade qui
est prônée par bergerat bergerac veut
jouer dans ce stade du côté de
versailles forcément bon n'est pas
d'accord parce que on n'a pas pu
recevoir à montbron donc on ne verrait
pas d'un bon oeil le problème et le
problème est donc on verrait pas d'un
bon oeil de jouer ce stade jouer dans ce
stade de périgueux donc il ya eu un
petit échange vous l'avait dit entre les
versailles et qui eux prônent plutôt
d'aller jouer au matmut atlantique et le
stade des girondins de bordeaux qu'à un
stade d'une plus grande ampleur 40 il
place ce à quoi a répondu le président
de bergerac christophe fauvel à l'écran
non mais le match minutes pour
accueillir versailles ça va les
chevilles du côté du château voilà le
match et est déjà lancé qu'est ce que ça
vous fait juste précis peut-être le
troisième solution qui est celle de
libourne qui est un stade qui à 60 km de
bergerac qui a déjà accueilli des
matches de ligue 2 entre 2006 et 2008
puisque libourne saint seurin évoluer en
ligue 2 à ce moment là c'est la
troisième solution évoquée le match est
lancé non bien sûr ça ça fait partie un
petit peu bu du folklore avant-match
quoi et apparemment les dirigeants
s'entendent plutôt bien en plus entre
les deux clubs est aussi mêlé floklore
com com ou non mais par contre je suis
d'accord avec versailles qui
quitteraient justement dit pourquoi on
donnerait la possibilité d'aller jouer à
périgueux que nous on a les mêmes
problèmes et nous on nous dit non donc
après que les chevilles enflent à
versailles ça c'est la taquinerie mais
c'est pas bien mais chaise c'est pas
bien méchant c'est bon enfant mais c'est
vrai que le tirage j'en ai parlé juste
avant le tirage je pense que claire la
ligne il au réseau a préféré la voir une
grosse affiche
stylo nantes où l'om est
une ligue 1 tout à votre
le plus mais et ce sera beaucoup plus
dur pour moi de passer
bergerac eux que tout cas dans ton club
alors on fait un petit tour de table
très rapidement vu qu'on est très très
bon dans dans les pronostics
les sites de paris en ligne font
énormément de chiffre d'affaires avec
nous
grégory un petit tour de table une
défaite de versailles 1 but à 0 audrey
j'ai envie de dire 1 0 versailles 1-0
pour versailles pierre dans une victoire
de personnes yann
ouais
comme pierre 2 0 pour versailles même 2
0 pour versailles au legends
versailles aux tirs au but versailles
aux tirs au but tout est enregistré en
tout cas on ressentira ça sur la
prochaine émission alors ce match de
coupe de france va arriver très très
vite ce sera ce mercredi 9 février à
18h30 et on ne connaît pas encore le
lieu mais ça sera dans le sud en tout
cas dans le silence c'est sûr on va
maintenant parler à tennis l'yvelinois
rinderknecht arthur et passer du rire
aux larmes à l'open d'australie le
français de 26 ans a tout d'abord
remporté une splendide victoire en cinq
sets contre le local pau pyrénées au
premier tour le score 7-5 4-6 6-2 3-6
6-3 un match très sulfureux dans une
ambiance bouillante avec un public
hostile un match qui a eu un impact sur
l'état physique du saint germanois de 26
ans il n'a pas réussi à s'aligner sur le
deuxième tour forfait car blessé au
poignet il n'a pas joué contre le
britannique dan evans comme prévu arthur
et 9,9 redescend même à la 60e place
mondiale
la question sur cette thématique est ce
que c'est une vraie déception finalement
cet open d'australie pour arthur et
n'empêche
oui pour vous genre oui pour vous pierre
non pour vous et yann très chauvin comme
toujours non pour vous à grégory et pour
voudraient ni dit mitigé alors on fait
un petit duel entre vous grégory et
pierre drai vous commencez par bien sûr
qu'on est con et déçu en tant que
suiveur d'artus rinderknecht le on le
suit depuis quelques quelques années
jamais non à ce stade là et on connaît
la carrière d'arthur moi je pense que
tout ce qu'il prend c'est du bonus il a
déjà atteint ce deuxième tour de l'open
d'australie c'est la deuxième fois qu'il
remporte un tour un match un match d'un
tournoi du grand chelem il avait déjà
passé un tour à l'us open là c'est une
blessure qui vient est bien l'empêcher
de jouer ce deuxième tour donc on ne
peut pas être déçu parce qu'il aurait pu
nous décevoir sur le terrain après avoir
gagné au forceps et avec la manière et
surtout le caractère je dirais le
premier tour face au joueur australien
donc maintenant c'est que du bonus la
bomba oui c'est un
un moment où il va devoir s'arrêter il
va se poser 15 peut-être un mois 15
jours un mois pour réfléchir se
repréparer revenir à son meilleur niveau
mais moi je pense qu'à ce stade de sa
carrière on sait tout son parcours il
arrivé tard sur le circuit c'est que du
bonus et finalement pas si de temps en
temps il est arrêté moi je peux pas être
déçu pour ça en tout cas pierre
chevaillier qu'est ce que vous lui
répondait alors vous vous êtes déçu oui
oui je peux pas dire autrement autre
chose compte tenu de ce qu'on avait déjà
évoqué sur ce plateau lorsqu'on lorsque
le lot peut-être un peu trop enflammée a
su rassurer leurs clients sur la
pression monte des émissions j'ai pas
entendu on s'était peut-être un petit
peu trop extasier sur la performance
d'arthur et 9,9 sur la dernière émission
c'est et on s'était peut-être peut-être
un petit peu emballé effectivement sur
leur sur le niveau d' arthur mais
justement je dirais que moi la déception
de provenir de deux choses la première
c'est que précisément l inverse de ce
que 10 de ce que dit greg c'est parce
que c'est une blessure que c'est que
c'est rageant et c'est extrêmement
décevant qu'il n'est pas tombé il n'est
pas ton et la raquette la raquette en
main au deuxième tour il n'a même pas pu
s'écrire donc ça c'est que c'est une
déception de fête et de contexte et pour
la deuxième raison c'est que c'est que
compte tenu du potentiel justement de
et de son image surtout et son injection
de son parcours sur le circuit pro
justement
26 ans il va il a plu autant de temps
qu'un jeune rookie qui viendraient
d'arriver sur le sur le circuit qui
ferait des étincelles il a un gros
potentiel il avait mon prêt beaucoup
avec une finale adélaïde et ce premier
tour contre deux australiens et en plus
il avait su se départir d'un contexte
justement assez hostile avec un public
n'était pas du tout acquis à sa cause
bien au contraire donc c'est une
déception de
ne pas l'avoir vu
s'aligner sur le deuxième tour et
confirmer tout le bien qu'on pense de
ceux de ce garçon après ça ne remet pas
en cause pour le pour autant les
promesses des promesses qui la porte
mais chirurgie sur l'open d'australie un
peu comme un monfils dont avait parlé
sur lesquels avaient parié dern
déception de ne pas avoir été
d'avoir vu lui peut-être aussi comme
alizé cornet audrey qui vous a convaincu
est-ce que c'est grégory est ce que
c'est pierre il avait de sacrés
arguments à tous les deux oui c'est vrai
que les 50 50 c'est pour ça que je suis
mitigé alors le terme déception je
n'irai pas jusque là j'irai sur un terme
de frustration en tant que grand sportif
à mme arthur quand on voit ces belles
performances lors de son premier tour
quelqu'un qui est extrêmement
impressionnant d'une certaine que cette
blessure lors les frustre ans alors tu
n'es pas seul parce que plus grands
sportifs de se remettre en question et
qu'elles sont à technicités elle est
vraiment excellente son talon d'achille
c'est une poignée quelque part il ya
vingt six ans il ya une espèce de
maturité qui peut effectivement
envisager anticiper c'est à dire que la
prochaine fois pourrait qu aucun défaut
ok tu manges la maturité de gagner et de
battre quoi qu'il arrive c'est vrai que
la frustration elle est présente nous ce
qu'on aimerait nous ce qu'on retient
finalement quand on voit arthur le jeune
arthur c'est que il ya une qualité de
jeu lors de son premier tour après quand
on est en sportif on a été témoin des
blessures et s'il a fait tilt anticipées
d'où la tête
n'est que partie remise pour arthur
vient du jarrier
qu'est ce que vous en pensez de
ce forfait au 2e tour
c'est une déception de ne pas avoir pu
faire le match maintenant voilà c'est
pas ça ne remet pas en cause son sa
qualité de jeu et c'est pas c'est pas un
problème moi par contre quand tu entends
pire qu il dit on aurait aimé avoir
voir les français aller plus loin deux
français en quarts de finale d'un grand
chelem moi je signe pour le même
résultat à roland garros avec moi bien
pas de souci ça fait quand même quelques
années que
ça dégage très rapidement sur les
premiers tours donc là là c'est vrai que
finalement moi gpa s'est emballée par
par cette femme c'est un tournoi et on a
vu quand même une finale une finale
magnifique qu'est ce que l'art sur elop
ne surclasse profiter cette finale à
votre avis il ya des gens riaient
est-ce que ce qu'arthur et n'appelait
j'aurais pu disputer cette finale à
votre avis
attendez il a passé il n'a pas joué le
deuxième tour entre le deuxième tour et
la finale il ya de la marge quand même
en plus il était quand même dans une
partie du tableau qui était très très
compliqué avec petit 6 passes avec le
bain des deux protagonistes demi-finale
medvedev ouais ça c'est medvedev
s'est il y avait quand même très très
gros le tableau du côté d'arthur était
beaucoup plus compliqué que celui du
côté de gaël monfils et de et de rafael
nadal
maintenant c'est vrai que l'on aurait
vraiment aimé le voir sur sur ce
deuxième tour pour pour confirmer tout
ce qu ils tous qu'ils n'ont compte dans
les ces derniers mois et c'est vrai que
ben dans le tennis on a souvent tendance
à ne retenir que les tournois du grand
chelem et c'est vrai que arthur là il
est en train de en train de tisser sont
sentis le laisse son début de carrière
ça lui laisse encore du temps et moi ce
que
contrairement voilà je pense qu'il a
entendu temps une nette de 26 ans et on
voir un rafael nadal daniel gagnier à 35
ans encore un tournoi du grand chelem
il reste du temps pierre chevallier
voulait répondre à yann
peuvent pas forcément répondre c'est pas
une déception de ne pas les voir au delà
d'un quart de finale parce que c'était
totalement inattendue en effet non c'est
juste par rapport à arthur sur le
deuxième tour il aura à affronter un
britannique et pour le coup c'est
peut-être que c'était tout l'univers et
tout jouable que deux australiens de
suie sur ces derniers sur ces derniers
matches en australie donc peut-être que
c'était plus ouvert
genre qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous
de cette de cet abandon avant de
diffuser son deuxième tour mais
malheureusement la blessure fait partie
intégrante de l'ue sportif donc je pense
qu'il peut être qu'un déçu dans la
mesure où il se sent très bien dans ce
tournoi qu'il avait fait un super
premier tour et sur la lancée il aurait
pu espérer comme l'a dit pierre en plus
d'être un adversaire qui était largement
à sa portée est malheureusement une
blessure ben c'est un petit peu le
malfrat s'est des tennismen mais on est
souvent blessé au tennis mais voilà
c'était la plaisanterie mais là il peut
rien malheureusement et mais encore une
fois et ça a été de sa déjà été dit ça
ne remet pas en cause ni en question le
le jeu le jeu tu peux avoir actuellement
et toute la halle à la positivité qui
peut il peut dégager par rapport à ce
jour nature inox neige je vais
maintenant prendre une pause pour
récupérer il n'a pas encore communiqué
sur ses prochains tournois et sa date de
reprise mais on le suivra avec attention
dans les prochaines semaines et pourquoi
pas à roland garros on passe maintenant
notre page débats
[Musique]
on va parler de boxe ce devait être l'un
des tournants de la carrière de tony
yoka le boxeur originaire de chanteloup
les vignes ne défiera pas le croate
filip hrgovic pour une demi finale yb f
des lourds en mars prochain la raison
ils ne seraient pas libres pour disputer
son gros bacs ce combat car il a un
contrat déjà signé avec le congolais bas
coller un adversaire qu'il aurait dû
affronter en janvier à paris bercy mais
le rendez vous avait été reportée en
mars suite à l'épidémie de kobe 19 la
fédération et bf basée aux états unis a
donc tranché et tony yoka ne pourra pas
affronter hrgovic une vraie déception
pour les viennois qui devra encore
patienter pour pouvoir disputer deux
gros combat en vue d'un titre de
champion du monde
la question sur cette thématique son
rêve d'être un jour champion du monde
des poids lourds s'est il envolé oui ou
non
est-ce que son rêve est brisé non pour
vous grégory
non pour vous pierre jan j'ai pas vu
non non non et partager bon vous êtes
tous plus ou moins en train de dire que
ce n'est pas terminé ans et ça j'en nom
peut pas dire que ce soit terminé mais
là c'est vrai que ça mais ça m'est
vraiment un goût de fringues il faut le
reconnaître parce que mais il avait il
il avait cette occasion à cette
opportunité de pouvoir aller se frotter
un grand en vue d'aller se frotter au
très grand et voir décrocher une petite
au suprême bon après je fasse quelques
uns une mauvaise gestion
une mauvaise gestion au niveau 2 de son
équipe parce qu'autour de lui parce que
là quand même privé se priver d'une demi
finale
d'un combat aussi important que celui là
pour sa carrière et la continuité par
rapport à un combat qui a été reporté là
je pense quand même qu'il est pas super
bien entouré après le gros problème de
base c'est surtout que le combat n'a pas
eu lieu parce que si rapporté pas assez
d'argent je me connais je jouais c'est
ça la ville et il n'était pas viable
parce que il ya veille avec hot 2000
l'argent c'était en 2000 et a donné l'un
des spectateurs comment
j'ai
à cause des jauges
les balles siffler on voit il fallait au
moins 7000 spectateurs à nîmes pour ce
soit viable donc donc il a été reporté
certes mais là on va dire que on va dire
que ce n'est pas fair-play bon
honnêtement ce n'est pas fair-play parce
que l'autre est très bien pu dire
sportivement je sais que dans ce monde
là c'est très particulier c'est très
très particulier mais on aurait pu
espérer qu'ils disent bon là là il ya
quand même l'opportunité d'aller
discuter un titre mondial enfin faisant
ce combat ça lui aurait peut-être ouvert
la porte
est ce qu'on peut en vouloir à baco les
finalement alors il faut maintenant lui
lui c'est prévu non non non on peut lui
en vouloir parce que voilà on arrive
notre français qui ont conçu aussi
pouvoir disputer cette demi finale et
avoir l'opportunité parce qu'on disait
la ceinture mondiale en 2022 pardon j'en
perds ma voix celle est très difficile
mais cette opportunité qui tombait un
peu de nulle part de voir cette
demi-finale contraire gaulle itx et bien
c'était vraiment une opportunité énorme
pour pour tony yoka et même d'être
challenger dès cette année alors que il
ya encore quelques mois ça semblait
complètement utopique maintenant on peut
pas lui en vouloir dans le sens que ba
lui se plie juste au contrat il a
signalé à libé est ce qu'il ya un
contrat qui avait été signée que dans ce
contrat effectivement avait été noté la
date de report et qu' il ya bien marqué
dans le contrat qui lie à un report
prévu en mars au moment où les jauges
seront levés on sait qu'il ya des sommes
en jeu on sait que la boxe et voilà
l'état d'esprit est plus individualiste
que dans d'autres sports et bah collet
n'en a que faire des rêves de ceinture
mondiale
il pense à sa carrière et pouvoir
affronter et tony yoka pour lui et
peut-être le battre ça peut être aussi
quelque chose d'énorme dans sa carrière
donc j'ai du mal à en fin je comprends
tout à fait qu'il qu'il n'est pas qu'il
n'est pas une n'est pas fait comment
dire fille de ce contrat qui est qu'ils
aient fait respecter son contrat audrey
qu'est ce que vous en pensez je rejoins
tchèque mais parce que faut quand même
rappeler qu'on est comme un contexte un
peu particulier légitimant le vide aussi
libre les jauges un changement
d'adversaire qui finalement l'adversaire
revient de la colle et a gagné en cours
pour mars tout ça c'est effectivement
c'est beaucoup d'enchaînements mais ce
qu'il faut ramener ça à ta mère je
gagnais du co en maturité activement son
ethnicité effectivement bas entre
blagues au lait est venu gastem de gros
spécimens qui concrètement un pompeux
alors la boxe ont été mêlés j'ai montré
ce que j'ai pu boire c'est quand même
deux coups au phénomène et je pensais
plutôt comme on dit la patience et la
quelle joie donc il faut savoir être
patient et justement la création notre
acquis qui gagnera peut-être balle
collet et tony yoka oui parce que
peut-être que macaulay pourrait battre
tony yoka aussi il faut il faut le
rappeler un pierre chevallier un réel
effet
c'est exactement sein et dans tous les
cas dans le dans le tracé de 2000 cas il
faut pas tout s'il veut un jour pouvoir
pouvoir se mesurer aux plus grands airs
le top 5 il faut se souvenir qu'il ne
souffre aucune pour par exemple face à
des boxeurs qui sont moins bien classés
qu'eux on avez ils s'étaient quittés en
fin d'année 2021 sur une sur la mal
chance dans ma malchance de joka re à
nouveau à nouveau sur le début janvier
quand on parle du report du match contre
monaco les rebondissements incroyables
et complètement imprévue 7,7 aussi demi
finales et la finale qui avait derrière
on point d'orgue en termes de coût en
terme de combat pour pouvoir permettra
yoka de ceux de se préparer mais là je
crois que je crois qu'il faut par ce
rétropédalage il faut quand même voir le
positif en préconisé comme disait audrey
il faut pouvoir cette fois pouvoir se
mesurer aux plus lourd qu'il soit classé
12e ou qu'il soit classé 6e 6e 4e et ça
donnera des combats de plus des du
mental et de l'expérience
pour aller jusqu'à son jusqu'à son terme
et de son objectif ça serait nettement
en 2022 mais on y croit et de toute
façon il faut il faut qu'il passe cette
étape a le choix
je précise quand même qu'on n'a pas
d'action c'est ni aucun n'en parle
quasiment chaque fois dans cette
émission mais c'est parce qu'il ya
tellement rebondissements depuis
septembre avec tony hawk a que l'on
parle à chaque fois sur tv 78 ya des
genres et qu'est ce que vous en pensez
vous
moi je suis je suis dégoûté pour lui
parce que en effet j'avais vraiment
l'impression que c'était l'opportunité
qui leur
disais sur l'émission
pardon finalement finalement il a un
petit peu malchanceux on en parlait sur
les pressions précédente émission
on est on est bien d'accord c'était une
belle opportunité et la ouais c'est
vraiment la malchance alors je la
mettrais plutôt sur un mauvais timing je
vais pas je vais pas aller par une
malchance j'ai plutôt parler de mauvais
timing et puis et puis voilà c'est pas
de bol d'avoir une le coup de malchance
et que la jauge elle et elle est arrivée
qu'elle lui a empêché de faire ce combat
auquel janvier et du coup ils se
retrouvent dans un mauvais timing avec
être l'obligation de faire un combat au
mois de mars et qui lui en qui
l'empêchent de pouvoir faire cette demi
finale c'est deux films ni finale contre
contre l'ukrainien c'est ce à quoi
tu crois pas donc voilà c'est juste un
mauvais timing on sait que le timing
dans la boxe c'est quelque chose de très
important il faut porter des coups au
bon moment donc j'espère que l'année
2022 lui être du coup une année de
permettre d'emmagasiner de l'expérience
faire des combats et de montrer en effet
qu'il est qu'à bac 2
qu'il est capable de confirmer qu'ils me
capable il va peut-être qu'en 2023 pour
pouvoir provoquer en 2023 l'opportunité
de pouvoir combattre il a déjà perdu des
années souvenez-vous avec avec leno show
donc c'est quelqu'un de patient je pense
une île il a cette capacité de 2,2
rebonds et puis il n'est pas il est
encore jeune 28 ans il a le temps la
catégorie des lourds
c'est une catégorie d'expérience il va
pour préciser il ya une jarre ya bientôt
trente ans pour tenir aucun
je sais pas si on va bien entendu yann
30 ans pour tony yoka grégory non mais
très rapidement ce qui est frustrant si
c'est con c'est là que tony hawk avait
aussi de grandes chances de l'emporter
face à goody qui sont rencontrées trois
fois chez les amateurs et tony hawk elle
avait battu à deux reprises lors des
mondiaux en 2015 et aussi aux jo en 2016
à rio à ergols il avait battu seulement
une fois en juniors donc c'est aussi ça
qui est très frustrant c'est que on sait
que ce combat était largement à la
portée tony hawk a très rapidement
comment on est quand on est dans la tête
de tony hawk à comment il est dans sa
tête la votre avis il s'était déjà
préparé à cette demi finale ib est fou
penser qu'il est dans quel état d'esprit
du coup je suis pas sûr qu'ils
équilibrent le temps ait eu le temps de
se préparer pour la demi finale quand
même puisque et mentalement à votre avis
non maintenant non puisque la ville
lorsqu'il est lorsqu'on lui a proposé ce
combat il a eu de suite certainement le
la pensée de dire mais j'ai déjà un
combat de prévu est ce que je vais
pouvoir aller aller sur celui là et
faire passer ça va passer en demi-finale
avant je pense pas qu'il eut le temps de
penser à ce combat
je pense qu'il doit être très très déçu
ça c'est sûr et on le saurait témoigne
mais mais il faut il faut qu'ils restent
concentrés parce que il faut à tout prix
par contre qui gagne ce combat là au
mois de mars parce que si par contre il
garder ben là là là ça me sa vraie à mon
avis un
bon tony hawk a en tout cas devrait donc
affronter abako les en mars à bercy on
va maintenant parler des jeux olympiques
d'hiver de pékin vous allez me dire que
cela ne concerne a priori pas les
yvelines et bien si chez le département
est un peu concerné par ce rendez-vous
une ancienne yvelinoise et plus
précisément plaisir aux incendies claire
va participer à l'événement planétaire
cet ancien pistard de l'équipe de france
qui a participé aux jo d'été de 2012 et
2016 va participer cette fois ci aux jo
d'hiver en bobsleigh à deux seuls sera
la remplaçante du duo féminin un an
après avoir arrêté le cyclisme à
s'élancer ce nouveau défi et elle a
réalisé de belles performances qui lui
ont permis d'être remplaçante sur
l'épreuve elle nous explique pourquoi
elle s'est lancée dans cette discipline
quand je faisais du vélo c'est mon frère
qui m'entrainait et en fait on délirait
france parti d'un délire où on disait
ben toi donc lui tu pilotera et puis moi
je pousserai et est en fait voilà j'ai
voulu vraiment tester ce que ça faisait
une descente de bob donc
voilà j'ai contacté la pilote margot boc
et puis donc ça c'était pendant le
confinement donc emprunter en 2020
et au final je suis allée essayez donc
je suis pas fait de descendre tout de
suite j'ai d'abord fait des tests sur
sur la poussée donc c'est vraiment
poussé le blog voir un peu bas si si ça
me plaisait tout ça mais moi c'était
vraiment d'abord dans un but c'était
plaisir quoi vraiment découverte et au
final j'ai accroché tout de suite est ce
que ce sport est vraiment différent du
cyclisme sur piste
elle nous répond alors les qualités
physiques
c'est les mêmes parce qu'il faut être à
la fois fort rapide donc puissant mais
par contre je passe d'un vélo donc un
sport portée
ben c'est de la course à pied en fait
pour s'entraîner on fait de la
musculation et de l'athlétisme du sprint
et là par contre c'est enfin moi j'ai
jamais couru de ma vie il a fallu que
j'apprenne à courir
savoir voilà bien pousser bien monter le
genou la pose du pied au sol c'est plein
de petits détails mais c'est hyper
technique la course c'est très très
technique donc c'était vraiment un
j'allais dire un pari un défi énorme
quoi
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
reconversion c'est la question sur cette
thématique yanni jarrier vous qui la
connaissaient très bien s'en dit claire
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous en
pensez de cette reconversion oui
oui je connais un petit peu 110 est vrai
que bah c'est une belle histoire ça fait
vraiment plaisir pour elle parce que
pascal arrêté un petit peu évincés par
en équipe de france d'une manière pas
très sympathique
donc donc c'est bien qu'elle avait calé
cette capacité de rebond et ce nouveau
projet
c'est une nana qui est qui est très très
gentille donc donc voilà on a grand
plaisir à la suivre et on espère on
espère même que
l add belle des belles perspectives
devant elle c'est des belles histoires
et que l'on aime dans le sport et je
confirme c'est vrai que pour un cycliste
passe et à la course à pied c'est vrai
que c'est quelque chose de très très
compliqué donc là elle arrive à rester
après haut niveau donc chapeau ça nous
fait penser peut-être un petit peu cette
histoire un lien aller originaire de
toulon à la fin c'est peut-être penser
un petit peu au film rasta rockett
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous en
pensez un genre vous avez réussi votre
fils se fait réveiller très bien pas
reconduit et ça c'est vrai mais par quoi
moi je suis dans mes shsh admiratif
parce que c'est pas évident du tout de
2,2 de passer d'un sport comme le
cyclisme est un sport comme le bobsleigh
qui est absolument rien à voir et d'être
aussi performant dans les deux camps je
lui tire mon chapeau franchement
être
incorporé les équipes nationales de deux
disciplines qui n'ont rien à voir c'est
la preuve d'une sportive accomplie reste
à roquette venant du film un film qui a
bercé mon enfance et qui est tirée en
plus d'une histoire vraie bon il ya
quelques différences entre cette épopée
jamaïcaine aux jo de calgary en 88 mais
il ya bien eu une équipe jamaïcaine y
avait lui-même 7 cette chute alors ce
pas une chute mais le bob qui s'était
renversé il avait tiré des images
d'archivés pour pour les exploiter pour
le film non c'est une belle histoire
pour pour sandie clair et en plus ce
qu'il faut souligner c'est que ça a été
une reconversion est clair en un an et
demi elle est passée du cyclisme sur
piste depuis qu'elle arrêtait sa
carrière mais en tout cas en un an et
demi elle est devenue très performante
en bob elle a fait quatre compétitions
et ça lui a permis d'être sélectionnable
pour ces jo et elle a manqué en plus à
quelques dixièmes de secondes la place
de titulaire voilà les titulaires qui a
lui échappé c'est un peu rageant de ce
point de vue là mais elle est elle voilà
elle prolonge cette ces histoires de
sportifs qui se reconvertissent et des
fois il ya de belles histoires il ya de
très belles reconversion d'un sport à
l'autre on en parle à juste après
voudrait qu est ce que vous en pensez
vous de cette reconversion
je pense que la reconversion ça a du bon
c'est vrai que c'est une champions qui à
35 ans donc elle est encore très jeune
là les conditions physiques et mentales
pour effectivement touché tout le sport
quand on aime le sport en aimant et de
toucher d'autres sports voit comme le
biathlon l'utilisation pas vraiment
quand on a cette mentalité
alors évidemment il ya quand même des
similitudes entre le sikhisme hellweg ya
les virages serrés la vitesse
la seule différence je pense que c'est
pour les cons c'est un peu plus
compliqué mais
ça sérieusement va jeter aussi marqué
par rasta rockett où c'est un tournant
bien il ya un esprit d équipe et c'est
tellement technique tellement clair que
l'impôt virage et l'a en fait on n'en
mène pas une personne mais plusieurs
personnes le sport individuel le sport
co n'a pas tous les mêmes mentalités
bouclage trouve que 110 elle assez forte
je pense qu'on fait là peu dur parce que
c'est un vrai challenge
pierre chevalier qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
mais je suis je résume ce jusqu'au ce
qu'ont dit nos amis sur son plateau avec
des vertus d'admiration et sucettes ce
salut de la résilience dont fait preuve
sandy caire je me demande même chance
sans savoir exactement la raison comment
elle a pu penser au bobsleigh après une
carrière accomplie de deux cyclistes sur
piste c'est parce que si c'est comment
cet homme car chevallier s'étaient
c'était plus du sport passion au tout
début finalement une blague avec son
frère et finalement de fil en aiguille
elle s'est rendue compte qu'elle avait
du potentiel et elle est assez lent
c'est tout simplement avec les membres
de l'équipe de france on a là un petit
peu discuté avec ses membres de l'équipe
de france est tout de suite à la fédé
super résultat
d'abord pas papa du coup sûr une piste
je sais plus comment on appelle ça une
piste de bobsleigh d'abord au niveau au
niveau des poussées et cetera sur des
compétitions et ensuite une piste de
bobsleigh du coup elle a testé ça et
elle nous a dit que c'était un peu comme
une comme dans une grande machine à
laver un cette piste de bobsleigh
c'est en ce sens qu'il ya une raison
comme celle
cessé mais pas un coup de chapeau qu'il
faut lui tirer parce que c'est vraiment
le c'est vraiment une une preuve de
résilience une preuve d'une preuve de
sportivité mais complexe pour le coup
est la sienne shauna seule chose lui
semble il semble comparabourse quel
petit lorsqu'elle présente à travers son
expérience est justement ces critères
d'explosivité la l'explosivité il faut
sur sur un cycliste sur un vélo sur
piste pour démarrer démarré avec des
watts envoie fort mais de la même
manière l'explosivité dont a besoin la
poussée
qui se fait sans les nommer un pied elle
doit réapprendre certain nombre de
gestes physiques et d'ajouter
d'entraînement pour pouvoir
magnifier ces qualités là mais déjà déjà
cette qualité mentale de pouvoir verser
d'un sport à l'autre et de le faire
comme le rappelait jean ou plus haut
niveau en équipe nationale c'est
absolument remarquable je précise inde
après 110 clair ce sera seulement la
deuxième française de l'histoire à avoir
participé aux jo d'hiver et d'été
je n'ai pas retrouvé son nom dans les
archives mais elle était passée du ski
de fond aux cyclistes cross-country donc
en gros il ya une passerelle entre
l'hiver et le cyclisme donc peut-être
que ça peut expliquer cela c'était dans
les années 90 ça parfois qu'ils ont une
délégation féminine de bobsleigh dans
des jo d'hiver la discipline qui
rentrait pour les faits pour la partie
féminine je parle bien sûr lors des jo
de salt lake city en 2002 et c'est après
on croit qu'il ya la france féminine aux
jo d'hiver et cette reconversion grégory
ce que vous pensez que c'est un peu ça
peut marcher ou pas ça a l'air de
marcher pour 1% 10 mais est ce que ça
marche pour tous les sportifs il ya
plusieurs exemples dans l'histoire le
premier qui nous vient à l'esprit ce
forcément michael jordan qui avait trois
titres de champion nba il a arrêté sa
carrière il est devenu joueur de
baseball une expérience très mitigée du
côté des white sox deux ans plus tard il
revient aux chicago bulls heidi gagne la
nba trois fois d'affilée mais il ya des
exemples de réussites de reconversion je
m'en suis noté quelques-uns luc alphand
qui est passé du ski à la course
automobile
il avait remporté le classement général
de la coupe du monde de ski alpin en 97
et en 2006 il a remporté le dakar dans
la catégorie automobile côté féminin je
peux vous citer l'exemple de rebecca
romero qui est passé de l'aviron au
cyclisme a été médaillé d'argent en
aviron aux jeux olympiques de 2004 à
athènes et ça ne lui a pas empêché
d'aller chercher l'or olympique en
cyclisme donc les reconversions sont
possibles mais par contre pour usain
bolt qui avait tenté une reconversion
dans le football savent et moi -
fonctionné c'est pas gage de réussite en
tout cas de change et d'une discipline à
l'autre très rapidement gens peut-être
un petit mot sur sur 110 clair ce qu'est
ce qu'on lui souhaite du coup pour ces
jeux d'hiver il souhaite beaucoup de
réussite et pourquoi pas une médaille
même si c'est quand on n'est qu'un pas
appelons les lois ton favori quand même
cette discipline alors l'équipe féminine
de bobsleigh est programmé du 7 au 12
février en chine à pékin et maintenant
ça sera le mot de la fin sur cette
émission malheureusement n'est déjà pas
dépassé le temps on va terminer comme
d'habitude par l'incitation aujourd'hui
je vous propose une citation du film
rasta rockett pour porter chance à 110
clair aux jeux olympiques d'hiver en
chine balance man cadence man traces la
glace c'est le bob man cool
rasta je vous laisse méditer sur cette
phrase à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]